this piece was inspired by the lacquer  Regency nightstand by anthropology I'm  filling in some cracks with wood filler  here I'm sanding the entire body of the  piece the oils from the wood will seep  through the paint and it'll look really  bad so you have to prime it  I'll usually do three coats of paint and  then after that I'll let it fully dry  after an hour it's fine to put that  polyurethane on it's like an extra layer  of protection on the paint my goal is to  make a piece look as close to the  inspiration as possible the second  priority is keeping it cheap but  Hardware does get very expensive so  sometimes I'll have to go with a cheaper  option I think it looks pretty similar  to the inspiration I will probably put  it up for 200 and hope I get 175 for it